during our first big-screen introduction
to Isla Nublar
many of us fell in love with the
Jurassic Park movies but in the 20-plus
years since then fans of uncovered many
mistakes and issues with the film's
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm explaining how drastic
world fallen Kingdom fixes or address
his six movie mistakes and complaints
fans have had about the Jurassic movies
spoilers ahead for the Jurassic world
movie so take care if you haven't seen
them yet
the brutal drawn-out death of Claire's
personal assistant Zara in Jurassic
world attracted plenty of criticism
Zara's demise which saw her being
pounced on by multiple Pteranodons and
snapped up by a mossis or certainly
seemed over-the-top given all she'd done
was loose track of Claire's nephews
after they were dumped on her for fallen
kingdom though co-writer Colin Trevorrow
says he learned his lesson and told
Empire that he made sure that every
death was earned everybody deserves
their death in this movie he explained
that it's horrible people who meet
brutal ends in the sequel like Ted
Levine's mercenary and Rafe's Paul's Eli
Mills the t-rex goat scene in Jurassic
Park is an iconic moment and there was a
brief callback to it in the first
Jurassic world yet some niggling
questions have been raised about the
original scenes such as given the size
of the goat why would a t-rex leave her
leg behind and not eat the whole animal
while in fallen Kingdom when the t-rex
is moved into Lockwood manors basement
and she eats the goat this time the
filmmaker specifically showed Rexy
swallowing up that final goat leg and
there's another little nod to that
Jurassic Park goat moment when Rexy is
chomping down on Eli Mills and one of
his legs flies off Carnotaurus catches
it
but then leaves it behind after being
scared off by Rexy by the way the t-rex
and goat scene was actually censored in
some countries like Italy and I talk
more about that in my video on falling
kingdoms deleted and censored scenes
something that worked many fans in
Jurassic world was how Clare managed to
spend the whole movie running around the
island in stilettos of course watching a
dinosaur movie means we have to suspend
our disbelief but seeing a t-rex outrun
by Clare he was wearing high heels that
never snapped just seemed a little too
silly and unnecessary Bryce Dallas
Howard defended her stilettos saying
they reflected how her character was
more at home in a corporate environment
and was
connected from the animals in the park
fallen kingdom director JB honor
acknowledged Jurassic world's heal gate
with his first shot of Clare in Jurassic
world - focusing on her heels in the
office elevator just like the first
movie however once Clare gets back on
the island she ditches her heels for
some sturdy boots a much more practical
choice for the sequels action scenes
although it's well known that many
real-life dinosaurs had feathers none in
the first Jurassic Park movie did in
fact dinosaur consultants on that movie
did recommend that dinos such as the
Raptors and the t-rex should have
feathers however unfortunately computer
animation at that time couldn't handle
creating feathers realistically so the
idea was abandoned the movie scientific
inaccuracy was acknowledged by Jurassic
Park 3s filmmakers who gave a nod to
feathered dinosaurs by adding a little
tuft of quills to the velociraptors but
when the franchise returned with
Jurassic world a decision was made to
stick with featherless raptors director
Colin Trevorrow defended this choice by
saying that Steven Spielberg had been
unhappy with the look and feel of
feathered dinosaurs in the Terra Nova TV
series which Spielberg executive
produced between the original and new
trilogy Jurassic while two addresses its
lack of feathered Raptors by adding a
little tuft of quills to the new Indo
Raptors head while still maintaining the
franchise's continuity by keeping the
overall scaly look of most of the
Jurassic dinos by the way the movies
have an in-universe justification for
the lack of accuracy and their Dino
designs as they aren't pure dinosaurs as
their genes have been mixed with for
example frog DNA and were explained in
Jurassic world that masrani wasn't
interested in realistic looking dinos
just scarier ones if their genetic code
was pure many of them would look quite
different but you didn't ask for reality
us for more TV though Jurassic Park 3 is
one of the less popular entries in the
franchise many fans do love the
Spinosaurus which was introduced in that
movie and key to designing that dinosaur
was Ricardo del Gallo
who contributed storyboards and concept
art for the creature Delgado is a film
and comic book artist he went and
credited for his contributions to the
movie however Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom pays homage to him with an
easter egg via congresswoman Delgado who
Claire speaks to on the phone to get
support for her plan to save the
dinosaurs from their impending
extinction on Eastland and blur from big
complaint that fans had about Jurassic
world was that there were too many CG
dinosaurs and not enough of the
old-school animatronic dinos they loved
from the original movie we did get an
animatronic Apatosaurus scene in
Jurassic world but Colin Trevorrow
explained that budget limitations meant
they were only able to write one scene
for an animatronic Dino first after the
financial success of that movie the
sequel had a much larger budget and it
hired Star Wars practical effects legend
Neal Scanlan to create new animatronic
dinos for the film Trevorrow who
co-wrote the script made sure to include
close-up scenes with blue t-rex and the
Indo Raptor the scene with the injured
blue were Owen xia Franklin and Claire
all interact with the Raptor is very
realistic and the use of animatronics
gave an opportunity for the actors to
have a real physical and emotional
connection to the Dino more than 10
people were under the table operating
blue during that scene and the creature
was even able to sweat and drool the
Indo Raptors close-up scenes also use
puppeteers to get more realistic and
scarier shots VFX was then also added on
top to enhance certain movements
difficult to replicate with puppetry
such as the blink of an eye or a snarl
now let me know what plot holes or
mistakes you spotted in fallen Kingdom
and what did you most enjoy about the
movie by the way I've got a new giveaway
for the first purge out now you can win
this cool 4k TV blu-ray player and purge
trilogy box set click the gleam link in
the video description to enter if you
like this video a thumbs up is really
appreciated tapleft for the top 10
fallen Kingdom deleted scenes or tap
right for my ending explained and
Jurassic world 3 video thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers